to britain now and queen elizabeth has
tested positive for covid19
she's received three doses of a vaccine
against the disease
buckingham palace says the monarch has
mild cold-like symptoms and will
continue with light duties in the coming
weeks the queen had met with her son
prince charles just days before he
tested positive for the virus early in
february
dw correspondent maas is following that
story for us in london berget how is
queen elizabeth handling the infection
so far
as usual buckingham palace is not giving
a running commentary on the queen's
health on any monarch's health we know
that she is in windsor and she's said to
have only light symptoms on social media
it's been reported that there is a wider
outbreak of staff
of kuvit in windsor but that's not not
something that buckingham palace has
confirmed however we do know that she
had met with prince charles and camilla
who both both
had tested positive of kovite but as for
now we only know that she is well
continuing uh to to have mild symptoms
and and and doesn't want to give up work
remarkably which yeah which and
typically for her of course uh but let's
not forget the monarch is 95 years old
and she's had health issues over the
last couple of months
how are the people in the united kingdom
reacting to the news
well absolutely she is 95 and as such
she is more vulnerable
even though the omicron variant is is
lighter but older people are more
vulnerable even if they are vaccinated
as as she has been i think a lot of
people will be relieved that the
symptoms appear to be mild but i think
it does put a spotlight on the
government's policy that
we still have tens of thousands of
people getting infected with omicron
every day however there are virtually no
restrictions and boris johnson is even
announcing that in the very near future
and the next days he intends to lift the
obligation for british people to
self-isolate if they do test positive
and also
testing will not be as widely available
as it is at present so i think the
monarch's illness at this age of 95 puts
a spotlight on the government's policy
and
you know there people will be asking
whether this is really the right
strategy
all right thank you biggit mars
in london